Okay, so let's now step a little bit away from the specific results in the Senate and in the house yesterday and think about
What this means for the future of political movements including the progressive movement, which is the one I care about
normally
It is a great time for the opposition party the party not in the white house to make progress
When you have a midterm after a presidential election Trump and Republicans winning in 2016 2018
Just simply speaking historically at the base level was supposed to be it was expected to be a good
Midterm for Democrats. However, the Senate was stacked against Democrats and what I mean by that is you that you had mostly
Democrats defending seats and
Republicans not you had a lot of Republican Senate seats that were just not up this year
So we already did the detailed results
But Dems won the house lost the Senate and did gain control of some new governorships, which I'll mention momentarily
I am going to need to talk some sense here to people on both sides of this so-called
Blue wave first of all on paper. It really wasn't a bad night for Democrats
I know that for a lot of people and I've been seeing the tweets and the emails it didn't really feel like it was a
Huge blue wave but you've got to understand that the degree to which it was stacked against Democrats in the Senate
Democrats with way more seats to defend because Republicans had 42 seats. They almost had a majority
42 out of 50 that weren't even up for re-election
They were totally impervious to the blue wave since they're simply not up for re-election. So yes Democrats were at a disadvantage
They've lost so far two seats net in the Senate
It might end up being three or four we will see
But Democrats did lose some key races that they should have been able to hold I mentioned the Heidi Heitkamp
Disaster I get it. It's the Dakotas but it shouldn't have been as lopsided as it was Claire McCaskill
Another example, I get it. It's not the most blue state, Missouri, but
Yet another race that I believe was bungled
So that is extraordinarily
Concerning in the House Democrats took control, which is great
Barely, though, they needed 25 seats in terms of a net gain
They got depending on where it'll be when when it's all said and done. Is it 28? Is it somewhere in the low 30s?
It's not totally clear the results in Florida were an absolute
Disaster Andrew Gilliam losing there for governor and Bill Nelson
Losing his seat to Rick Scott in the Senate Florida really big disaster for Democrats
For governorships. It actually overall was a really good night
Democrats gained seven governorships yesterday a net gain of seven and
Republicans had
Understandably obviously a net loss of seven seats that being said
Stacey Abrams in Georgia lost by just one point nine percent in Georgia and
There was voter suppression there. It's not actually clear to me that she lost
I got a couple calls yesterday from people saying David should beta or orc contest the results in Texas. I don't think so
I don't know that that that's that beta or orc lost because of foul play
in Georgia, however
Where you had the guy running the election Secretary of State Brian Kemp?
Also running as the Republican candidate for governor and you had deregistration voter purges
Limited voting hours closed polling places and in the end. It's that tight
I do think that that's one that needs to be looked into other
Governorships that went the way of Democrats Maine is a good one
Michigan is interesting. Wisconsin is
Absolutely huge where Scott Walker was defeated. The guy is disgusting and it is so great to see him kicked out
Illinois Democrats took over the governorship
Kansas where
Nightmarish Kris Kobach was defeated and we'll talk about that a little more New Mexico and Nevada saw
Governorships turn blue. And to me, this is one of the biggest wins from last night taking over. The house is very important
but taking over seven governorships is so important because
This is now seven more states that could decide to follow the Paris climate guidelines
Even if Donald Trump calls the United States out of that agreement at the national level
this is seven more states that can legalize marijuana as some states did and
restore voting rights to felons as some states did or protect workers rights, which Scott Walker was not doing in
Wisconsin quite the opposite so that is really really big and then the other good news from yesterday is
That if you look at some specific states, you see that trumpism
Destroyed them and I want to go back to Kansas
the very red state of Kansas where Donald Trump defeated Hillary Clinton by 20 points in
2016 56 to 36. They have a Democrat who is going to be governor defeating Trump
Crony Kris Kobach Democrats in Kansas. Also took one of four House seats
from an incumbent Republican and the person who took it is
Cherise David's which is huge. So in Kansas, we've really seen how
bringing in this cut taxes and defund social programs, Sam Brownback
right-winger-ism, trumpism
I don't know what name you want to assign to it it led to a definitive leftward move for Kansas
That is really great news
And then also good news are the ballot initiatives, Florida banned
Offshore drilling and banned indoor vaping they restored voting rights for felons
Michigan legalized marijuana by popular vote. They will be the tenth state to legalize marijuana
That's a clear trend nationally and it's of course going to continue the momentum continues to build
So listen, the big picture is Democrats took the house
They didn't lose that much in the Senate given how the races
Favored Republicans, they gained seven governorships and a bunch of different progressive
Ballot initiatives were passed. We won the popular vote
In Senate races by 12 million votes if you count for two Democrats running in, California
It's more like nine and a half million votes and won the popular vote overall. If you look at the popular vote across
Everything that happened yesterday at the net you know
Governor's House and Senate Democrats won the popular vote by about eight percentage points. That's a blow out
Okay in American politics, that is a blow out by any
Standard, so Republicans do need to be very worried. There's all the positive stuff
Okay, that that we're getting out of the way but here's where it starts to get very very ugly
First of all does taking over the house and plus seven governors?
Do a damn thing about turning around the corporate takeover
Of our political system and our economy for the last 40 years. The answer is it doesn't do a thing
And it's not fair to expect that you would change that with one election
And I know that we can say well there have been some
further
Leftists that won in the house AOC in New York and some others, that's fine
But only if they're able to achieve change. Is that going to be a success point so number one?
when I see
the most destructive and ignorant president in decades
Single-handedly destroying important geopolitical alliances around the world making the United States look like a joke
insulting everyone making economic policy with the total lack of understanding of the consequences of that policy and
Democrats barely take over the house. I'm not
Just blaming voters. I'm not just blaming the Democratic Party, but we've got to get it together
Okay, if you care about what's going on, you have to vote and I know voter turnout was up
I know that it was but it's got to be up more because otherwise we're getting crushed in 2020
okay, if there was ever a time to vote wasn't it yesterday and meanwhile
It's great that Democrats took over the house and gained seven seats in terms of governor's but there is still no
cohesive Democratic strategy
There is this jumping back and forth between playing Republican light and being more progressive
Being the sane centrist and being Republican light in this constant revolving door and most importantly because it's okay
To run races differently based on where you're running. That's not the issue the issue. Is that Democrats?
big-picture
With exceptions are not speaking to voters in a way that truly resonates in terms of why
Shouldn't they be afraid of losing their status?
Perceived or real if they support Democrats that was one of the top
motivating factors for people voting for Donald Trump the fear of losing the status they either
perceive they have
Actually have or think maybe they would have at some point in the future
I'm not saying that Democrats need to run the exact way that Republicans run because then we're just
Republicans that's not the point I'm making
but if so many people
you have the right policies within a
Reasonable sort of Overton Window if you are a Democrat on many issues
But the voters aren't understanding that and that's a communication issue fundamentally
And then also they ran a lot of crappy campaigns
How can the Democratic Party expect to win when this is what they're able to do?
after two years of Trump and
Some of the worst governance that we've ever seen. I am not one to defend Michael a vanadis political approach
I have my problems with them
but the one area where I do agree with avenatti is that he says we actually need to fight and that
Doesn't mean compromise our principles
It doesn't mean do things that we find immoral
But Trump will crush us in 2020 if we continue the waterfalls and Ginger Snaps
Approach that too many but not all Democrats take you can't be Republican light
you can't pretend that you don't need to play the game period and if you are disappointed and
You should be to some degree even though there were victories last night. We have a new project
We have two years now where the goal is clear. Take over the white house
Take over the Senate expand control of the house and get a majority in terms of governorships
And I'm going to be talking about that shortly
Today's program brought to you in part by Blinkist
dot com slash Pakman. Blinkist is a great service that I use all the time. What they do is they take
thousands of the most popular
Nonfiction books including the newest bestsellers. They condense them into 15-minute
Audiobooks that you can listen to and you still get the most crucial information and insights from each book
And I've listened to a ton of books on Blinkist
I recently checked out Soccernomics by Simon Kuper
We do have after all the World Cup going on recently
We also have been talking about BS jobs and there is a great new book BS jobs by David Graeber
Which I listened to on
Blinkist, they're constantly adding new books to the platform. You will never run out of
Fascinating and critically acclaimed books to enjoy and our audience can get a seven day free
Trial by going to blinkist.com slash Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I'm putting a link in the video description and after the free trial if you'd like it you can continue enjoying
Thousands of condensed audio books for about five bucks a month. That's B L I N K I S T
.com, forward slash,
P A K M A N